mesdames messieurs bonsoir c'était un
film cette mort sur ordonnance depuis
l'année dernière c'est une tragique
réalité un médecin Jean-Claude roman âgé
de 38 ans employé à l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé à Genève avec une
carabine 22 long rifle à tuer à
Clairvaux-les-Lacs son père et sa mère
aimait et Anne-Marie roman et a
Prévessin moins dans l'Ain sa femme
Florence âgée de 37 ans sa fille de 8
ans Caroline et son fils de 5 ans
Antoine puis il a tenté de se suicider
en mettant le feu à sa maison
l'intervention des pompiers la sauvé il
est actuellement à l'hôpital de Genève
grièvement brûlée
le mobile de ses actes n'est absolument
pas connu sur place personne ne comprend
un témoignage celui de son propriétaire
sympathique on avait il avait le bonnes
relations avec tout le vaginal c'est moi
pour moi c'est incompréhensible parce
que
c'est vraiment c'était vraiment un type
sympa et doux je veux pas comprendre ce
qui s'est passé et tous les gens du
voisinage pour vous dire que c'était un
type vraiment sympathique
ce qui s'est déclenché on peut pas je
peux pas le comprendre
après Vincin moi personne ne comprend à
Clairvaux-les-Lacs personne ne comprend
non plus sur place sous sa face est un
état de choc la famille roman qui vient
de perdre 5 de l'heure dans le drame que
nous venons d'apprendre était très connu
et très estimé ici selon les premières
informations recueillies c'est une amie
de la famille qui aurait découvert le
père et la mère du médecin Jean-Claude
roman
le père du praticien aimait roman était
en garde forestier en retraite il avait
74 ans et coulait des jours sans
histoire avec son épouse Anne-Marie 69
ans pour leur personne le désir trop
parler de ce drame une chose est
certaine beaucoup de monde ici se
questionnent ce soir sur les mobiles qui
auraient poussé Jean-Claude roman à
commettre les réparable et à propos de
toutes ces questions voici une réponse
apportée par une voisine aimée et
Anne-Marie roman les victimes étaient
très connu et très estimé à
Clairvaux-les-Lacs
il venait souvent leurs enfants leur
rendre visite
quand même assez souvent bon l'été là il
passait leurs vacances ici pour Noël ils
sont allés faire Noël vers eux ils sont
restés trois jours
il semble qu'il y avait aucun problème
avec leurs enfants
donc ce drame ne s'explique pas moi je
ne l'explique pas les suites de
l'enquête sur la tuerie de Prévessin
dans l'un selon les gendarmes l'après
méditation de Jean-Claude roman qui a
tué je vous le rappelle 5 membres de sa
famille avant de tenter de se suicider
l'après méditation semble maintenant
établie de plus en plus le meurtrier
apparaît comme un mystificateur qui
menait une double vie le point avec nos
envoyés spéciaux fille boiserie Jacques
Gérard son nom ne s'écrivait pas tout à
fait comme un roman pourtant sa vie il
l'a écrit comme tel ou plutôt sa double
vie car même si la détruit sa famille
brûlait une partie de sa maison il n'a
pu effacer les deux chemins qu'il a
suivi cela pendant presque 20 ans celui
qui l'a mené ici à Prévessin lui
demander de faire comme si de s'abonner
à moult revue médical de participer à
des Colocs scientifiques bref de leurrer
son entourage ses amis sa famille
l'autre chemin les gendarmes tentent de
le remonter ils ont découvert comme le
symbolisme à BMW un train de vie de haut
niveau mais aucune trace d'un quelconque
salaire d'un quelconque travail depuis
12 ans pas d'impôts non plus les
enquêteurs ont déjà identifié 900 000
francs versés depuis 90 qui payaient sa
maîtresse parisienne par amour ou par
promesse d'intérêt fructifiant mystère
ce qui est sûr c'est que cela ne
suffisait pas loin de là et que Romain a
aussi cherché à supprimer ce témoin
gênant d'une vie déchu d'autres ont-ils
payé en échange de placement juteux
promis par un respectable médecin seuls
les nombreux comptes bancaires pourront
le dire à moins qu'à l'hôpital de Genève
la santé du meurtrier continue à
s'améliorer et autorise un
interrogatoire alors romance aura que
les chemins ont fini par se retrouver
dans une chambre d'hôpital dans la folie
Jean-Claude Romand meurtrier présumé de
cinq membres de sa famille le week-end
dernier a été transféré de Genève dans
un hôpital français dès que son état de
santé le permettra bien sûr les
enquêteurs l'interrogeront sur les
nombreuses zones d'ombre de son
existence l'enquête de Philippe boissery
et Jacques Gérard sur place
le bail de la location de sa maison
latexte Jean-Claude roman se faisait
bien passer pour chercheur et chaque
mois il lui fallait trouver beaucoup
d'argent 7000 francs pour le loyer au
moins 15000 francs pour la location de
la BMW plus la voiture de sa femme plus
l'école privée des enfants l'entretien
de la famille les voyages de vacances
ces déplacements plus particuliers au
total au moins 40 000 francs par mois
l'analyse de ces comptes bancaires n'a
pas encore résolu l'énigme certes en
1991 une de ses anciennes amis lui
confie 900 000 francs elle vient de
quitter la région et de vendre son
cabinet médical elle ne sait comment
placer l'argent roman propose ses
services elle hésite pas par méfiance
mais par crainte de d'ennuyer son ami
elle ne reverra plus jamais les fonds
lorsqu'elle téléphone roman invoque des
problèmes de santé un cancer pour ce
défiler selon les gendarmes roman aurait
multiplié cette opération en échange
d'une juteuse rémunération pourtant dans
le village et dans son entourage tout le
monde jure que roman ne parlait jamais
argent à qui a-t-il alors emprunté
comment a-t-il pu tenir pendant plus de
15 ans sans jamais travailler si les
enquêteurs ont fini de déblayer la
maison ils n'ont pas bouclé l'enquête
ils espèrent pouvoir interroger le
principal intéressé la semaine prochaine
alors que dans son jardin sa folle
double vie n'est plus qu'un tas de
cendres
Jean-Claude roman a craqué cet homme qui
a tué toute sa famille avant de tenter
de se suicider a reconnu les faits
reportage fille boissery lorsqu'il a
fini par reconnaître sa vie cachée
Jean-Claude roman aurait lâché cette
simple phrase je suis un monstre
pourtant durant des heures il a tenu
tête au juge d'instruction venue
l'interroger ici à l'hôpital
pénitentiaire de Lyon il ne voulait
présenter qu'un visage celui du médecin
discret sympathique cet après-midi son
avocat a vu un tout autre homme
quelques journées de coma un homme qui
est qui est abattu oui ça c'est je peux
pas dire autre chose et qui regrette
peut-être
pour l'instant il n'a pas je peux pas
dire quoi que ce soit sur sa manière
d'aborder son dossier entre temps acculé
par l'effet il a reconnu l'assassinat de
ses enfants de sa femme et de ses
parents découverte aussi cette existence
de dupe menée pendant presque 20 ans
grâce à ses proches qui laisse croquer
en proposant des placements avantageux
sur le point d'être découvert il a
préféré tout détruire pour échapper à la
déchéance et peut-être aussi pour éviter
la honte au sien lui a raté sa fuite en
manquant son suicide il devra donc
assumer l'étrange film de sa vie devant
la justice
bonjour à tous les assises de l'un
jugent à partir d'aujourd'hui l'une des
affaires les plus incroyables de ces
dernières années amistomane qui se
faisaient passer pour Médecins depuis
plus de 20 ans a tué toute sa famille
Dominique verdaillant Michel janoulatos
on était bien placé
et puis la route
Odette était bien placé mais depuis
trois ans elle a face à ses fenêtres ce
qu'on appelle dans le village la maison
du malheur la maison de Jean-Claude
roman celui qui s'est avéré faux
médecins et qui s'est avoué un vrai
criminel enfin voulez-vous qu'on y pense
pas trois ans qu'on voit cette maison
devant les yeux
pourquoi il a fait ça à sa femme qui
était très gentille et puis les gamins
aussi pourquoi
c'était dans la tête
veut comprendre alors elle lit et garde
tout ce qui est écrit sur la ferme sur
son voisin un homme apparemment sans
histoire apparemment seulement car sa
vie n'était que mensonge en janvier 93
un incendie ravage la maison de roman on
le retrouve inanimé sa femme ses deux
enfants ont été sauvagement assassinés
mais l'horreur ne s'arrête pas là car
roman a également tué ses parents roman
se disait médecin chercheur à l'OMS à
Genève en fait il ne dépassait pas la
frontière il restait dans sa voiture a
compulsé des revues médicales pour faire
semblant une errance un mensonge qui a
duré 18 ans
alors ça c'est une explicable ça c'est
quand même un acteur de première force
pour pour tromper autant de monde
pendant aussi longtemps c'est sûr
acteur ou mythomane devant un jury
populaire Jean-Claude roman pour la
première fois ne pourra plus mentir
au procès on va retrouver Dominique
verdaillan alors Dominique j'allais dire
l'affaire judiciaire paraît cruellement
simple puisque roman a reconnu les faits
mais le procès durera toute une semaine
il y a des mystères à percer oui le
mystère d'un homme car c'est d'abord le
procès d'une double vie d'une vie en
trompe l'oeil c'est quelque chose qu'on
a c'est une personnalité qu'on a
rarement vu dans une dans une cour
d'assises un scénariste aurait inventé
cette histoire on dirait il en fait un
petit peu trop et bien pourtant
l'histoire de Jean-Claude roman elle
commence très tôt elle commence à la
Faculté de Médecine puisqu'il va faire
croire à son épouse qu'il a réussi les
examens de médecin qui les médecins en
fait c'est déjà faux c'est totalement
faux il a pas été plus loin que la
première année il va s'inscrire 12 fois
de suite en deuxième année de médecine
sans se rendre à la Faculté de Médecine
alors après bien c'est l'engrenage celui
qui consiste à faire semblant à faire
illusion habilité de Jean-Claude romain
c'est pas un médecin qui soigne c'est un
médecin qui cherche à l'OMS à Genève
alors de temps en temps il se dit
spécialiste de l'artériose propose de
temps en temps il va passer avec sa
famille devant le bâtiment de l'OMS à
Genève et il va montrer deux fenêtres en
disant à sa femme et à ses enfants vous
voyez c'est là que je travaille encore
une fois c'est faux alors ce qui est
assez incroyable dans cette affaire
c'est qu'il n'y a eu aucun soupçon de
son épouse oui on se pose comment
subvenait-il à ses besoins il n'était
pas médecin il faisait croire il allait
j'ai lu sur des parkings de supermarché
lire des revues scientifiques toute la
journée il disait je rentre du travail
le soir mais comment tu venait-il à ses
besoins comment nous récit-il sa famille
écoutez il a spolier ses amis c'est à
dire qu'il disait bien voyez moi je suis
en Suisse donc je peux faire fructifier
de l'argent prêtez-moi de l'argent en
tout il aurait détourné deux millions et
demi de francs qui a été son train de
vie en quelque sorte et c'est
probablement parce que ses proches ont
voulu récupérer cet argent qu'il ne
pouvait pas et qu'il est passé à l'acte
préférant que que c'est que sa famille
que ses proches et bien ne connaissent
pas la vérité
au procès de Jean-Claude roman à
Bourg-en-Bresse on a découvert
aujourd'hui une autre facette de la
personnalité de semi Thomann qui après
avoir menti sur sa vie professionnelle
pendant plus de 15 ans assassiné toute
sa famille demi-que
avoir un médecin dans la famille c'était
pour les proches du couple un honneur
tout le monde était admiratif vis-à-vis
du docteur roman tous avaient une
confiance illimitée ainsi lorsqu'en 88
il ausculte un oncle qui souffre d'un
oedème tout le monde se réjouit même
s'il propose un médicament miracle
venant de Suisse moyennant finance 4
flacons de 6 gélules 60 000 francs
versés en liquide roman n'a qu'une
réponse il croyait bien faire tout aussi
accablant le témoignage du pharmacien du
village pharmacie ou travaillé parfois
l'épouse de roman 4 jours avant le
quintuple assassinat roman est venu pour
acheter des barbituriques pour ses
recherches a-t-il dit pour l'accusation
c'était pour endormir son épouse avant
de l'assassiner
ainsi se dessine le portrait peu
flatteur d'un mythomane assassin
calculateur mais aussi escroc et
charlatan un homme qui aujourd'hui fait
une drôle de confession le seul être
acquis il ne mentait pas c'était son
chien en France au procès de
Bourg-en-Bresse Jean-Claude Romand après
avoir raconté pendant 48 heures c'est 15
années de mensonges s'expliquait
aujourd'hui sur son quintuple crime sa
femme ses enfants et ses parents
Dominique verdaillant Michel Janot
mensonge ou réalité Jean-Claude roman
est dans l'impossibilité de raconter ses
crimes il ne lui reste que des flashs
des images impossible aussi d'évoquer
les derniers instants de ses propres
victimes alors roman sanglotte pleure
s'écroule dans le box hurle et
s'évanouit le 9 janvier 93 roman tue à
l'étage son épouse Florence pendant une
heure il reste avec ses enfants au
rez-de-chaussée je les câline puis je
vais chercher la carabine dit-il après
quoi il va acheter son journal ensuite
il prend la route du Jura des jeunes
avec ses parents avant de les tuer ainsi
que leur chien il fallait que ma fille
et son chien près d'elle s'englotte
l'accuser le soir départ pour Paris où
il tentera d'assassiner son ex maîtresse
puis retour chez lui où il restera toute
la journée du dimanche près des trois
cadavres le lendemain matin Jean-Claude
roman met le feu à sa maison
la mort c'était le seul passage pour
éviter la souffrance celle de la vérité
ainsi remontant de s'expliquer à
lui-même ses cinq crimes se livrant à
une pseudo-analyse qui t'apprend le box
des accusés pour un divorce avec le
quatrième jour du procès de Jean-Claude
Romand aux assises de l'Ain hier la cour
est revenue sur les 5 assassinats commis
par la fusée aujourd'hui il était
question de la tentative d'assassinat
contre l'Aix maîtresse de Jean-Claude
roman et du suicide raté de ce dernier
récit d'une journée électrique Didier
Bouillot yvonani
un avocat en lieu et place d'un témoin
qui se constitue partie civile pour ne
pas venir à la barre le scénario était
attendu pour ce quatrième jour
d'audience il a débouché sur un débat
procédural laissant les familles
interrogatives et Jean-Claude romance
spectateur d'un autre procès car son
défenseur faisant assauterloquence exige
la confrontation avec son ancienne
maîtresse roman l'a entraîné dans un
guet-apens en forêt de Fontainebleau au
soir du 9 janvier 93 c'est le moment le
plus important du procès dit l'avocat
avant de demander l'interruption le
renvoi du procès à une date ultérieure
si nécessaire c'est un témoignage
important puisque c'est la seule
personne qui a survécu à ce processus
criminel terrible il est important
qu'elles viennent dire ce qu'elle a vécu
il est important qu'il y ait un débat
contradictoire c'est un principe
essentiel devant la Cour d'Assise
éteignant le débat la cour réserve sa
réponse sur cette audition jusqu'à mardi
soir car il y a des contradictions entre
les déclarations de cette 6e victime et
la version donnée par Jean-Claude roman
au micro un roman trouve le moyen de ne
pas être sur les lieux son récit du
déroulement de cette soirée est tiré des
procès verbaux il les connaît par cœur
quel était votre intention demande la
présidence il y avait-il une intention
réponds roman il est vrai que la
tentative d'assassinat qui lui est
reproché reste flou Lavocat général doit
se faire virulent pour obtenir des
réponses sur les faits
mais une impression s'impose faux
médecins un roman paraît d'avoir été un
faux amant qui s'était inventé une
histoire d'amour que l'argent réalité
matérielle a brisée face à ses faux
sanglants à ses mensonges roman est
resté toute la journée du 10 janvier 93
dans sa maison de prevessin-moëns aux
côtés des corps sans vie de sa famille
dans l'actualité également devant la
cour d'assises de l'un le dernier jour
du procès de Jean-Claude roman avant que
les jurés ne se retirent pour délibérer
l'accusé à implorer le pardon de ses
victimes compte-rendu d'audience
dominger
ils ont attendu plusieurs heures
certains ont même préféré déjeuner sur
place nombreux sont ceux qui voulaient
vivre un instant de vérité dans cette
histoire de mensonges certains viennent
depuis le premier jour du procès mais
aujourd'hui tout le monde n'a pas pu
pénétrer dans la salle
ainsi ils n'ont pas pu entendre les
derniers mots de roman dans le box
l'accusé se lève et fixe sa
belle-famille c'est peut-être dit-il la
première et la dernière fois que je peux
parler à ceux qui souffrent à cause de
moi le débit est saccadé la voix
légèrement chevrotante je leur demande
pardon même si ce pardon viendra
peut-être après ma mort puis roman se
tourne vers les pièces à conviction il
regarde les photos des siens de ceux qui
l'a tué vous êtes là vous êtes présents
mais maintenant dit-il vous connaissez
tous les secrets des cœurs le secret des
larmes pardon d'avoir brisé vos vies
l'atmosphère est pesant entre roman se
confesse mais ni la famille ni les jurés
ne regardent l'accusé tout le monde
pense d'abord aux victimes cette
déclaration m'a ému parce que elle
montre sa volonté d'expier ses crimes et
puis elle s'adresse aussi aux familles
qui sont malheureusement durement
touchées et auxquelles il demande pardon
ce matin l'avocat général avait requis
la perpétuité avec une période de sûreté
de 30 ans le maximum de la peine parce
que pour lui les crimes de roman ne
peuvent que provoquer la nausée alors
qui est Jean-Claude roman le monstre
froid ou l'homme blessé celui qui selon
son avocat aimait les siens comme un
malade qui les aimait à la vie comme à
la mort à moins que les jurés ne
considèrent ce soir que roman n'a pas
encore tout dit madame monsieur bonsoir
celui en qui les experts psychiatres ont
vu une rage narcissique qui a un
invraisemblable aveuglement ou une
monstrueuse dynamique de succès
Jean-Claude roman a été condamné mardi
soir par la Cour d'assise de l'un à la
réclusion criminelle à la perpétuité a
sorti d'une période de sûreté de 22 ans
il avait en janvier 93 tuer sa femme
leurs deux enfants et ses parents
compte-rendus d'audience Dominique
verdayan et Michel jenoulatos
un verdict accueilli avec calme avec
sérénité un verdict sans surprise
perpétuité a sorti d'une période de
sûreté de 22 ans au lieu des 30 ans
requis les jurés ont donc tenu compte de
la personnalité à ses troubles perturbés
de Jean-Claude roman une circonstance
atténuante que n'avait pas écarté
l'avocat général dans ses réquisitions
et il est dépassé par ce par ce procès
je crois que il a essayé d'affronter la
justice et ses juges et en définitive il
se retrouve ce soir face à lui-même dans
des conditions d'abattement que vous
pouvez deviner la cour d'assises a
répondu oui à toutes les questions 5
assassinat et une tentative sur la
personne de son ex maîtresse ainsi que
le détournement de 2 millions et demi de
francs pour la partie civile ce procède
était aussi une volonté de rupture avec
l'ex gendre idéal bien sûr que c'est un
procès que nous attendions je respecte
ce verdict évidemment
après ce verdict qui a été très chargé
en émotion
il faudra essayer de tourner une page
tout du moins essayez d'oublier
Jean-Claude roman dans ces derniers mots
roman s'était adressé aussi un à ceux
qui l'a tué en faisant une drôle de
supplique il leur demandait de l'aider à
trouver le chemin de la vérité
[Applaudissements]
retour en France Jean-Claude roman le
faux médecin condamné pour avoir
assassiné toute sa famille a fait une
demande de libération il est en fait
libérable depuis trois ans sa peine de
sûreté ayant expiré son affaire
invraisemblable à marquer les esprits
elle a inspiré un roman et deux films
peut-on libérer ce prisonnier pas comme
les autres Dominique verdaillant et
Frédéric Bazille
incarcéré depuis 25 ans Jean-Claude
roman est libérable lui qui incarne une
vie de mensonge en juin 96 alors qu'il
fait son entrée dans le box on découvre
le vrai visage de Jean-Claude roman faux
médecins mais authentique meurtrier un
homme en apparence sans histoire alors
que sa vie durant 18 ans ne fut que
dissimulation tout commence par
l'incendie de sa maison en février 93
Jean-Claude roman y a mis le feu après
avoir tué son épouse et ses deux enfants
dans la même journée il s'est rendu à
quelques kilomètres de là il a déjeuné
avec ses parents avant de les tuer d'un
coup de carabine son entourage découvre
alors un autre homme c'était vraiment un
type sympa et doux je veux pas
comprendre ce qui s'est passé cinq
meurtres et une vérité qui éclate
Jean-Claude roman n'a jamais été médecin
à l'OMS en Suisse il ne passait pas la
frontière mais restait dans sa voiture
pour consulter des documents médicaux
une vie sans travail sans salaire
contraint de rembourser ceux à qui il
avait emprunté de l'argent pour vivre
Jean-Claude roman remplace le mensonge
par le crime
âgé de 64 ans c'est un détenu modèle
offrant des garanties d'emplois et de
domicile les experts psychiatres qui
l'ont examiné et carte tout risque de
récidive un avis partagé par ce
praticien il y a un défi de se reprocher
dans la vie sans sa famille sans ses
parents donc au fond d'une certaine
manière la prison est protectrice et il
y a un moment où peut-être le sujet a
trouvé en lui l'idée de refaire une vie
Jean-Claude roman pourrait être libéré
de la centrale de Saint-Maur à la fin du
mois
dans l'actualité donc cette décision de
justice il avait été condamné à la
prison à perpétuité pour avoir assassiné
cinq membres de sa famille en 1996 dont
sa femme et ses enfants dans la maison
familiale installé dans l'Ain après
avoir purgé une période de 22 ans de
sûreté Jean-Claude roman connu pour
cette fait passer à l'époque pour un
médecin de l'OMS et libérable depuis
2015 mais aujourd'hui la justice a
estimé que ça demande de libération
conditionnelle n'était pas recevable il
reste donc derrière les barreaux
Béatrice Tardi Marie Le Robert
les experts psy avaient donné leur
accord pour sa sortie mais le tribunal
d'application des peines a rejeté sa
demande de remise en liberté
conditionnelle Jean-Claude roman qui a
assassiné en 1993 5 membres de sa
famille restent donc derrière les
barreaux de la maison centrale de
Saint-Maur dans l'Indre l'homme est
pourtant libérable depuis 2015 pour
mettre à Bad son avocat depuis plus de
20 ans la déception est à la hauteur de
ce projet de remise en liberté
longuement préparé
je suis très déçu alors je ne sais pas
si on va relever appel de cette décision
ou non j'en ai pas pris connaissance de
manière détaillée mais le projet était
sérieux le parcours de roman était
exemplaire et par conséquent même si la
justice doit prendre en considération
l'effet aussi dramatique qu'il soit le
grossiste tourné vers l'avenir voilà et
je pensais qu'elle se tournait vers
l'avenir en acceptant cette demande vous
savez je ne leur vis pas même s'il avait
été admis dans le cadre de cette
aménagement de peine c'est une
souffrance quotidienne cette souffrance
simplement est accentuée par rapport à
tous les efforts qu'il a pu accomplir et
par rapport aux gens qui ont cru en lui
et qui ont participé à l'élaboration de
son projet voilà ce que l'on peut dire
ce soir le tribunal a estimé que son
projet ne permettait pas un équilibre
entre le respect des intérêts de la
société du droit des victimes et sa
réinsertion il a dix jours pour faire
appel son histoire terrible a marqué le
pays de Gex car pendant 18 ans chaque
jour Jean-Claude roman quittait sa
maison de près sa moinds pour travailler
à Genève à l'OMS sauf que tout était
inventé il n'a jamais été médecin à la
barre du tribunal de Bourg-en-Bresse il
a avoué avoir tué ses parents sa femme
ses pour leur éviter d'apprendre le
mensonge d'une vie
alors pour l'un des psychiatres qu'il
l'avait auditionné avant son procès la
chose est entendue roman n'est plus
dangereux écouter Daniel setlaine au
micro de Franck Grasso et Arnaud Jacques
c'est le genre de personnages qui
récidivent pas ça ils peuvent pas
comment vous qui récidive
comme il a dit il a tué tout ce qu'il
aimait maintenant il est
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on appelle un
raptus mélancolique et on pétage de
plomb si vous voulez donc pour vous en
fait le fait que la liberté
conditionnelle ait été refusée c'est une
erreur c'est plus une erreur je pense
qu'ils ont j'ai peut-être décrit je n'ai
pas tous les éléments en main mais je
pense que
vu de l'extérieur pour moi rien ne
s'oppose à ce qu'il puisse sortir
d'ailleurs il remuera sa demande dans un
an Jean-Claude Romont a eu gain une
cause en appel la justice lui a accordé
une remise en liberté conditionnelle
même très encadrée cette libération
suscite l'incompréhension parmi les
proches des victimes mais après 26 ans
de détention la défense se félicite
d'une telle issue le point avec quand
walgit sing
après 26 ans derrière les barreaux il va
retrouver la liberté la demande de
libération conditionnelle de Jean-Claude
roman vient d'être accepté par la cour
d'appel de Bourges elle lui avait été
refusée en première instance et
aujourd'hui son avocat estime que la
justice a fait son travail
et je peux vous dire que le sentiment
que j'exprime à cet instant c'est le
sentiment également de Jean-Claude roman
Jean-Claude roman et bouleversé il est
pas heureux il est malheureux il est
bouleversé c'est une souffrance à l'état
pur alors je sais que les victimes
souffrent aussi je sais qu'elle
désapprouve cette décision en juin 1996
Jean-Claude roman a été condamné à la
perpétuité pour le meurtre de sa femme
de ses deux enfants et de ses propres
parents pendant 18 ans il avait menti à
ses proches prétendant être médecin à
l'OMS à Genève mais en réalité il ne
travaillait pas et escroquer de l'argent
à son entourage jusqu'à ce que la
supercherie soit sur le point d'être
découverte et qu'il passe à l'acte
aujourd'hui Emmanuel Crawley son ancien
beau-frère cette demande de libération
conditionnelle acceptée est une nouvelle
trahison la justice lui permet de le
demander il le demande ce qui nous
quelque part est un certain affront il
faisait des victimes et de nous c'est
qu'il l'est osé le demander et qui
n'aille pas à l'issue de sa peine qui
est une perpétude une perpétuité mais
qui aurait pu être regardée au bout de
30 ans ce qui nous fait mal et ce qui
est synonyme d'un coup de massue un coup
de poignard dans le dos c'est le fait
qu'il ose demander de sortir
un Clairvaux le village où Jean-Claude
roman a assassiné ses parents les
habitants sont mitigés concernant sa
prochaine libération
non ça me plaît pas
parce que il a fait toute sa famille
quand même
c'est très dur à dire mais moi
sincèrement ça me gêne un peu
avec les atrocités qui se sont passées
je trouve pas ça juste c'est tout quand
on a une peine on va jusqu'au bout je
pense que quelqu'un qui a vécu déjà
pendant 25 ans en prison il a le droit
peut-être de
comment dire de trouver un chemin dans
sa vie quand même
d'après le parquet Jean-Claude roman
devra quitter la prison de Saint-Maur
avant le 28 juin prochain et portera
pendant au moins deux ans un bracelet
électronique il lui sera également
interdit de se rendre dans plusieurs
régions de France et notamment
Rhône-Alpes ou résident encore des
proches c'est une abbaye sous
surveillance pour l'arrivée ce matin de
son nouveau pensionnaire Jean-Claude
roman le faux docteur qui a tué cinq
membres de sa famille en 1993 vivra
désormais parmi les moines après 26 ans
de détention il a été libéré cette nuit
selon les psychiatres le risque de
récidive est minime mais dans ce village
de l'Indre sa présence s'inquiète
certains habitants
j'imagine que pour qu'il soit libéré il
fallait il fallait un projet de
réintégration et que c'est l'église qui
lui proposèrent ça ça me fait un peu
bizarre quand même mais bon après voilà
une libération sous condition
Jean-Claude roman âgé de 65 ans porte un
bracelet électronique pour au moins 2
ans il a interdiction de se rendre dans
les régions où il a commis ces crimes et
ne pourra sortir qu'à des horaires fixés
par la justice le faux docteur a quitté
en pleine nuit la prison de Saint-Maur
pour son ancien beau-frère cette
libération est un choc
pendant deux heures malgré tout on se
prépare jamais une telle annonce on
était loin de s'imaginer la douleur et
la tristesse que ça pourrait nous
engendrer en janvier 1993 dans sa maison
de lin Jean-Claude romantus son épouse
et ses deux enfants de 5 et 7 ans puis
il se rend à quelques kilomètres de là
chez ses parents et les abats froids
avec une carabine l'épilogue de 18 ans
de mensonges celui qui se disait médecin
à l'OMS avait en réalité échoué en
Faculté de médecine et passer ses
journées à errer dans sa voiture ses
revenus de l'argent confié par ses
proches à qui il promettait déplacement
rentable
au moment de son crime Jean-Claude roman
était sur le point d'être découvert en
1996 il a été condamné à la perpétuité
il était libérable depuis quatre ans
[Musique]